this is such a strategic time on YouTube
right now and there's a major Temptation
in pull right now a lot of people
probably 95% actually start to kind of
check out I mean it's December it's
holiday parties it's been a crazy year
there's so much drama in the world and
everything that's happening man I just
kind of want to hide away maybe rewatch
The Office maybe get a little bit of Ben
and Jerry's maybe just kind of watch Elf
and jump on Disney plus and go through
the Christmas movie rabbit hole all of
that's cool but there's such an
opportunity right now to really go all
in on YouTube and one of the things to
understand about YouTube is the seasons
and the times and The rhythms as it
pertains to views and really as it
pertains to money to be made on the
platform so let me illustrate it this
way November December and January so
really the next 60 days are the most
profitable times to be on YouTube and I
can prove it to you so let me take you
behind the scenes and share with you um
the analytics from our Channel think
media and share how much money that we
make now of course this is all relative
and we have you know a larger Channel
but I want to share with you how much
money we earned last year and talk about
how strategic right now is okay so if we
go to how much money we earned on my
channel think media okay and what we're
looking at too is less about the dollar
amount but but let's go back and what we
could see is actually January of last
year and December of last year and then
I think we scroll down we got June
January December here's here's my point
look over on the far right side and
actually this is kind of good to know I
was reviewing this with some of our team
and sometimes we don't dive deep into
our analytics but what we can look at is
not only do you go to your analytics you
go to revenue but then you want to go to
the how much you're earning see more and
now you're in an advanced Analytics and
what you're going to be comparing here
is you have the opportunity to not just
see what your estimated Revenue was um
but you also get to see your
CPM and your CPM again is the amount of
money advertisers are willing to pay for
um on your videos now cpms vary and so
this is going to be different if you
have you know viral re-uploads of Tik
toks and Cat videos versus personal
finance versus uh DIY videos they vary
but what happens in November December
and January is advertisers ad spend goes
up which means your Revenue go your
Revenue goes up if your CH channel is
monetized okay so what does that mean it
means that strategically the more
content you can post and the more views
you could get the more money you can
make and in a way not because you're
doing anything different but because the
environment is different it's the season
where cpms are higher and so what I can
actually see here is that in January and
December we're at 2 279 and 2183 uh
November was
2236 and so that was some Peaks if you
will and then uh I mean it all kind of
hovers throughout the year around there
at least for us this is our experience
but then if I look at my ad Revenue now
January last year 50 Grand uh that was I
think the peak of the Year lowest being
like 32 and there's the other reason of
it's not just your CPM and your RPM
which let me know what yours is you
could drop it in the comments have you
noticed this different or maybe your
experience is different as does it
actually go down right now I'm not sure
but as a rule advertisers they're trying
to do all their holiday sales they're
getting their messaging out there okay
the other thing that's happening is
there's strategic times a year depending
on your type of content people are
hanging out at home more they're may be
watching it more like what we've noticed
is not just November and December is
holiday shopping and we talk about tech
and so this is a very strategic time to
do camera reviews really or video
reviews we do camera reviews it's a
strategic time to do like product
reviews what product could you review in
the next couple weeks what product
comparison could you review in the next
couple weeks what video could you do
that's a tutorial about a product in the
next couple weeks connected to affiliate
marketing right strategic time but the
other thing is you just want to think
about psychology and mindset so what
happens for us in in January is
everyone's like okay new year new me
it's time to start my channel it's time
to get focused on my channel it's time
to spend my gift card and buy that
camera on Amazon because I'm going to do
YouTube year and so the spike is also
just based on January has a lot of
momentum because of people's mindset and
what's so important for us is to think
strategically about our entire year like
you want to be hustling when when people
are paying attention but there's other
times when people are may be more
checked out call it summer so rhythms
for different channels can be different
but my challenge to you how can you make
strategic videos right now that position
you to maximize December but also to
prepare for January and and I'm not
saying like you shouldn't be definitely
resting and recovering and family that's
one of our biggest values family is
everything but we're PL the the people
who had the best results they're they
don't start planning and New Year's
resolutions on January 1 they start
planning December 1st if not earlier
they're more strategic a month ahead two
months ahead of everybody else and 99%
of people are like I'm just gon to check
out until next year man I'll maybe get
serious on January 1st don't get serious
on January 1st get serious right now if
you enjoy this podcast and are ready for
some deep dive YouTube strategy just go
to think masterclass.com to get access
to my 1hour on demand YouTube strategy
class you'll be looking over my shoulder
as I share my best tips and you can
watch it on Demand right now at think
masterclass.com